mientras la ocupación de ucrania
continúa la maquinaria propagandística
rusa ha aumentado en la mañana del
miércoles rusia 24 un canal de
televisión nacional estatal emitió este
vídeo afirmando que ucrania estaba
preparando un ataque nuclear contra
ellos mismos priman el chiri turista un
grupo de saboteadores ucranianos quienes
atacaron la central nuclear de savory
allá incluso provocaron un incendio los
combatientes de la guardia nacional rusa
los repelieron el objetivo es claro
culpar a la federación rusa en otras
palabras es terrorismo nuclear
yerli ser el ángulo ruso siempre tiende
a centrarse en un aspecto en particular
el hecho de que supuestamente los nazis
controlan ucrania
este experto especialista en temas de
defensa de estas una agencia de noticias
rusa acudió a la televisión nacional
para hablar sobre el texto resultó
meterle poder no se puede descartar otro
peligro la negligencia criminal de los
dirigentes ucranianos especialmente con
la ideología de los curas rusofobia y
neonazis
pero hay una razón por la que esta
propaganda es tan persuasiva y eficaz
sobre el pueblo ruso
y la propaganda es un fenómeno bastante
complejo siempre se construye en dos
partes está la parte negativa que
remarca la imagen del enemigo con todo
ese discurso de amenaza a la seguridad
nacional la otra parte es el discurso
positivo nosotros rusia el poder ruso
putin no hacemos más que el bien
defendemos a la gente honesta luchamos
contra la nación
según un estudio local reciente desde la
invasión a ucrania vladímir putin goza
de un 71% de aprobación